Mandol dm The cold is approaching
The developer preview version 6, which was released earlier,
I'm driving a Mars test.
If you have not tested your app yet
Why do not you start testing now?
Hello I'm Google TV web hard What is CANA YES
From now on you will be able to test your app on m Premier Sea
I'll also briefly see what new features are available
Let's take a look.
Let's get started right away. M Developer preview skt on
It contains mlauter device image development document sample code and so on
Go to the next developer preview site to see all the tools and resources you need
can
Before you get started, you should have one correct version of skip, especially the fast boot
Failure to do so may result in errors when uploading system images.
There is
So let's first look at how to download the m developer's skills.
I'll do it
Developer Preview sk is an Android studio
You can download it from 2.3 version impression.
Or you have another one for preview version testing
Download the latest version of Android stew from the site, especially s
wish
Next, you need to update your Android droid to version 1.3 or later
Open the Preferences or Settings menu and select the update item
Select
So that one can receive updates to the Android studio via this channel.
Select and update app
If you run the Android Dio again and enter the update item,
Roll also sdk in Korea, you can choose a grass roots channel
Press check or button and wait for a while
If you choose not to use gsk, the new sk platform and preview version
You can install the tools
We are almost ready to test the m developer preview version
I do not want to skate because g2g has all the sk
When you create a project, you can select the target sk as m primers,
Modify the grades file on the plate so that the scale version entry is not compiled.
You can set it to mnc. Do not forget the double quotes.
Next is the time to prepare the device. If you want to use the emulator
You can use mnc x86 system image by avd major
There is
Of course, it would be better to use the actual device than the oliter.
As you have been told for the first time,
live69tv r You can upload new direct system image
There is one thing to note:
All data on that device will be erased
Please backup important data in advance.
If you are using a Mac or a x or x line
You must allow OEMs to unlock
Then, after rebooting the device with the boot loader menu via the add command
Starts each command without a fast boot oem
At this time, the device is initialized and all data is deleted.
Go to your system image and execute the script command of flash protection
Wait a minute and your device will bootloader baseband firmware and os
Will be updated in order
I'm finally ready to test the m developer preview version
As always, upgrading will cause compatibility issues.
m as well as the preview version, visit the developer's site at
You can see the various breaststrokes at a glance
Let's look at some of the major changes.
Let's start with a summary of the new tribulation request model.
If you use an api that requires specific permissions in your app, you
You will be able to choose whether or not to allow the issue
Users will have better control over the behavior of their apps,
I am worried that the update rate will be lower because of the update c addition.
You do not have to.
At the same time, however, while the app is still installed,
May not exist
Even if a previous installer is installed,
You can explicitly choose which permissions to grant
So, before you can use features that require specific permissions,
Be sure you have it
In camera apps, the necessary camera access rights
If you have the necessary permissions to run,
You might want to ask the user to accept the permission
Autobackup is a hands-on experience for developers.
This is a new service that allows you to sell 105
m If you have built a target, you have 20 megabytes
It's free, and your app data automatically shows up on your Google Drive
Will be encrypted and stored
Of course, you can not back up specific data with additional schema files.
You can specify it explicitly or you can not use data backup
May be
New backup manager adb shell command to test automatic backup function
Has been added, and in this version of the amp, regardless of the target sk version of the app,
Backup function is activated
When the version is officially released, the Emmy version is targeted
This feature will only be enabled for apps
Rose mode and app standby mode both use the device's battery
This is a new feature in mParser to optimize
The escape means sleeping in the Korean language.
If the device is not used for some time without any movement,
In addition, apps that have not been used for a long time after installation will be in standby mode
Is activated
In both states, the system allows your app to use at least
I will suggest the functionality of your app
You may not be able to use the network,
It can be supported and the device can not be woken up
Even under these circumstances, you need to test your app
There is
The following new ad commands have been added
To test the escape model, the command
The following commands are available in the app standby mode test lab
Added as an add command to test newly added question recognition api
It was.
You can also use the add finger touch command to enter 10 fingerprint assumptions
There is
Please keep your developer feedback a few times before the m version is released.
We will release an improved preview version based on
And when the platform is stable enough and always works, the full version
Will be released
In fact, the first line before final release means this process
Whenever a new version is updated, sdk and device image
Will be updated
For your own convenience, you can use the
When you update, the preview of future versions will be automatically updated via ota
Will be
There are many other features in the bundled version
Test the various features and see how the new apr
Please check to see if you can improve
Join the developer community and use the Issue Tracker to
Please forward it to us
Also, for Korean developers, Google Korea also has mplab related
Developers and developers can test m version devices directly
We also have space available.
For more information, please check the gdg Korea page
Thank you
e25
woo lee